بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على اشرف الانبياء
والمرسلين وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين اخي حضره
حاضب الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود ملك المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال
سعود ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسمو ملوك والرؤساء
وامراء الدول العربيه الشقيقه معالي السيد
احمد ابو الغيث امين عام مدين امين عام
جامعه الدول العربيه اصحاب المعالي
والسعاده الحضور الكرام السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
انه لا من دواعي السرور ان نجتمع في مدينه
جده عروس البحر الاحمر وبوابه الحرمين
الشريفين واسمحوا لي في مستهل كلمه ان
اعبر عنه خالص الشكر والتقدير والامتنان
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه ملكا
وحكومه وشعبا على ما حضينا به من حفاوه
الاستقبال وكرم الضيافه وعلى الاعداد
المميز لقمتنا هذه كما يطيب لي ان اتقدم
بعميق الشكر الى اخي فخامه الرئيس عبد
المجيد تبون رئيس الجمهوريه الجزائريه
الديمقراطيه الشعبيه الشقيقه على ما بدله
من شهود من جهد مقدر خلال فتره الرئاسته
للقمه السابقه والشكر موصول لمعالي الامين
العام لجامعه الدول العربيه وجهاز الامانه
العامه على ما يبدلونه من مساعي حديثه في
سبيل خدمه العمل العربي المشترك اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسموم الحضور الحضور
الكرام يلتزم مجلسنا الموقر في ظل ظروف
دقيقه
وتحديات متشابكه
تفرزها الازمات المتفاقمه في وطننا العربي
والمتغيرات الاقليميه والدوليه المتصارعه
وبالطبع فانه لا سبيل الى مواجهه تلك
التحديات الا من خلال مواقف عربيه موحده
ومتماسكه ترتكز على استراتيجيات واليات
عمل جديد جديا وفعاله تذكر من تربيه
التطلعات الشعوب العربيه
التواغ الى الوحده والتكامل على جميع
الاصعده وتسهم مفيدات الوقت في ايجاد حلول
عمليه الاستراحه التي تعصف ببعض دولنا
ويدفع ثمنها الابرياء من ابناء امتنا
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو ان قوتنا
تكمن في وحداتنا
وتماسكنا في دعم القضايا العادله لامتنا
وفي مقدمتها القضيه الفلسطينيه التي تمر
باحلك الظروف في ظل امعاء امعان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في التنكيل بالشعب الفلسطيني
الشقيق الاعزب
وفي هذا الصدد فاننا نطالب بالزام الدوله
العبريه باحترام القانون الدولي الانساني
ووقف الجرائم الحرب التي ترتكبها وتوفير
حمايه الدوليه للشعب الفلسطيني وتعشيد
الطاقات العربيه
وتكثيف الجهود من اجل من اجل اقامه الدوله
الفلسطينيه قابله للحياه على حدود الرابع
من يونيو لعام 67
وعاصمتها القدس الشريف وفقا لقرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه ذات الصله ومبادره السلام
العربي وفيما يتعلق بسوريا الشقيقه فاننا
نرحب بعوده بعوده هذا البلد العزيز الى
الحضن العربي
معتبرينه ذلك خطوه هامه نحو تعزيز التعاون
العربي المشترك ونثمن الجهود العربيه
المكثفه التي بذلت بهذا الخصوص لمساعده
سوريا على الخروج من ازمتها
وانهاء معاناه الشعب السوري الشقيق التي
امتدت على
مدار الاعوام الماضيه وفيما يتصل باليمن
الشقيق فانما نجدد التاكيد على موقف
جمهوريه جيبوت الثابت الى جانب الشعب
اليمني الشقيق وقيادته الشرعيه على كافه
المستويات معربين عن تفاؤلنا حيال اجواء
السلام التي اضحت تخيم على المنطقه على
خلفيه التقارب بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه والجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه والذي انعش الامال
بخفض التوتر في اليمن وتعزيز الامن
والاستقرار الاقليميه
ونشيد في هذا السياق بجهود حكومه المملكه
لاحياء العمليه السياسيه والتوصل الى حل
سياسي شامل ومستدام وفق المرجعيات المتفق
عليها وتحت اشراف الامم المتحده وحاول
تطورات الوضع في جمهوريه السودان الشقيقه
نؤكد مجددا حرصنا البالغ على امن واستقرار
السودان وسلامه اراضيه كما نعبر على
ترحيبنا بالجهود المحليه والاقليميه
والدوليه الهادفه لوقف اطلاق النار وتهيئه
الظروف الملائمه لحوار سياسي شامل وننوه
في هذا المضمار بالمحادثات الجاريه في جده
بين بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع برعايه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبصفتها عضوا في لجنه الايجاد الايجاد
للمكلفه بالوساطه في الازمه السودانيه فان
الجمهوريه جيبوتي ستواصل مساحيها لتنسيق
المواقف مع باقي دول الايجاد المنخرطه في
هذه الوساطه ومع الدول العربيه كذلك
مؤكدين على اهميه التضافر جهود الجميع من
اجل انهاء الازمه في اسرع الوقت وبشان
ليبيا الشقيقه نؤكد دعمنا الكامل للجهود
المبذوله لانهاء الازمه الليبيه عبر تسويه
ليبيه ليبيه بما يحقق المصالحه الوطنيه
ويسمح بتنظيم الانتخابات في اسرع وقت ممكن
ويحفظ وحده ليبيا وسيادتها ويصون مقدراتها
ويلبي طموحات شعبها الشقيق في الامن
والاستقرار والازدهار
وبخصوص المستندات في الصومال فاننا نشيد
باجواء الانفتاح والاستقرار السياسي التي
بدات تباشرها في هذا البلد الشقيق كما
ننوه بالمساعي الذي تبدلها حكومه الرئيس
حسن الشيخ محمود لتحسين الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والامنيه ونؤكد في
الوقت ذاته ان الصومال لا زال بحاجه الى
دعم اشقائه
ومساندتهم له في تحقيق تطلعات شعبه في
الامن والاستقرار والتنميه اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسمو اصحاب المعالي والسعاده
اننا في هذه المرحله الصعبه والدقيقه من
تاريخ عار من العربي بحاجه الى وقفه جاده
وصادقه للتامل في حال الامه وواقعها
المريض بغيه الدرء المخاطر التي
ما
فتنت تزداد تعقيدا وتجديد عزيمه الصمود من
اجل الدفاع عن حقوق شعبنا شعوبنا وصون
مقدراتنا مقدراتها والدول عن حياضها ونحن
مفعمون بالامل والتفاؤل في ظل تولي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه لقياده
الدفه العمل العربي المشترك انطلاقا من
ثقلها من ثقلها ودورها الرياضي وحرصها
المعهود على لم الشمل ونصره قضايا الامه
وفي الختام اجدد الاعراب عن وافر الشكر
والتقدير للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه ملكا وحكومه وشعبا على استضافه
هذه القمه والاعداد الجيد لانجاحها سائنا
المولى عز وجل ان يكلل اعمالنا بالنجاح
والتوفيق
وان يوفقنا جميعا لما فيه الخير والصلاح
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات